gilles aqua pas mais oui mais oui mais
oui mais moi j'ai un coup de gueule
c'est quoi c'est quoi contre le maire
jean michel maire qui racontent
n'importe quoi qui dit que rihanna qui
fait sur lui au parc des princes
dimanche soir lors de psg om oui oui il
a dit ça j'ai bondi hier il a dit ça ici
on peut voir ce qu'il a dit oui on peut
voir c'était patrick êtes vous un peu
papounet match de foot hier soir au parc
s'est fait rihanna les repas qui m'a
regardé je le dis sans veut s'en sont à
la gournerie avec beaucoup d'insistance
j'étais limite gêné pour djezzy qui est
à côté geneviève letarte ne se tenir
prêts au cahier non bruit qu'ils soient
prêts pour et donc rihanna n'a pas du
tout craqué sur jean michel vernhes on
en a la preuve en image rihanna elle est
venue au parc des princes pour passer la
soirée prendre une photo et kevin trappe
le gardien regardez comme il est bon
kevin trap est plus beau plus le banc
que jean-michel il est plus beau que mr
oui regardez
regardez
[Musique]
dagan donc c'était votre filiale aia pas
facile ce genre si elle voyait jean
michel vous passez de des pics elle
s'est jetée veille bras de trappes
mr oui jean-michel oui mais oui vous
vous êtes mariés vous je l'étais il ya
longtemps en 1981 ça date un peu mais
j'ai un coup de deux d'entre eux jean
michel maire
hier j'ai regardé l'émission et j'ai
bondi parce que ben laden avec qui
fêtera dimanche ses fours et n'importe
quoi on peut regarder si vous voulez
merci vers l'egypte mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison ça l'est parce que c'est lui
qu'elle est sévère mais rihanna merci on
va voir la gueularde du jour tout de
suite le fait d'avoir quitté grenoble
est ce que ça vous avez ici un goût amer
mr
à
[Applaudissements]
ce qui vient de les regarder l'émission
j'ai bondi pas ce qu'il a dit n'importe
quoi sur rihanna qu'elle l'avait quitté
marseille le maquis fait garder si vous
voulez mais si vous voulez un très bon
jeu le permet on regardera pneumologie
de bon faire des saluts hier dans 7 à
vous c'est héréditaire aussi paraît que
c'est peut-être ça vient du père et de
la mère mère j'ai un coup de gueule
contre jean michel aulas qui hier j'ai
bondi quand j'ai regardé l'émission j'ai
bondi quand j'ai regardé l'émission on
peut regarder si vous voulez c'est bercy
gilles verdez merci à eux
non mais c'est merci en tout cas il faut
savoir que rocco siffredi donc vous la
vidéo de leyme bertrand il faut bien
s'en occuper très bien s'en occuper
ouais c'est vrai vous en occuper bien
oui vous inquiétez pas encore mieux que
de jean michel lemaire maire
j'ai un coup de gueule contre jean-louis
pendant l'émission j'ai bondi de mon
siège parce que vous l'avez dit crié
allah vous avez tout fait pour garder si
vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
mais garder le public de slam s'il faut
regarder cette ambiance mathieu dans
cela